est ce que les français pu on me demande
ça souvent mais c'est pas du tout les
cas je pense que tout le monde prend sa
douche à ingré sont toujours hallyday de
que les français soient dupes et
révolutionnaire donc le sang chaud et
c'est vrai depuis que je suis ici c'est
les grèves tout le temps les français
avec la petite barrette
t-shirt avec des rêves et bien sûr la
baguette sur sous les bras et un peu les
manches ddd la france et franchement je
comprends vraiment pourquoi
qu'est ce que vous faites bien les pins
avant je m'en foutais complètement
événements je peux pas manger autre
chose que ce pas vraiment des bons pas
français parce que comme je rentre en
espagne les pins idée vraiment horrible
c'est les gros mots petite histoire par
exemple j'étais je marchais dans la rue
avec une pote une française elle fera
une copine qui est en train de fumer en
terrasse dans un petit café elles soient
et [ __ ] mais ça fait longtemps mais
jamais de la vie au royaume uni tu fais
mes fans français elles font vraiment là
que partout et aussi dans les
supermarchés il ya là que parce que la
cassière se prend du temps pour palais
avec leurs clients en allemagne et faire
les courses par exemple ça c'est
vraiment de le stress est faux l'acacia
les communes robot est raide se
dépêchent vraiment et les clients le
même alors il faut être vite pour pour
payer parce que sinon tous les restes
être énervons énerver les français il
parle beaucoup de la nourriture ils sont
vraiment fiers fiers de cette
gastronomie qui vous représente
justement je suis devenu une fou dit
alors qu'avant je l'est pas du tout et
puis ça fait cinq ans j'avais carrément
dire que j'ai bien grossi à cause de ça
en grèce les grecs adorent le mannequin
français c'est celui là avec le couleurs
neutres avec la ligne blanche pense
toujours que c'était son très chic et
très belle très propre je me suis rendu
compte que les françaises ne font pas du
mal et du français
c est que c'est considérer un triptyque
le galettes de rois
mais c'est un truc qu'on rencontre
bizarre j'étais chez les amis et en
france un garçon il a ramené une
un gâteau mais c'est même pas qu'est ce
que c'était et il a commencé à couper
cette gâteau là le truc vraiment très
bizarre c'était kabila s'est mis sous la
table j'ai trouvé un site web qui est
qui est beaucoup
ça se passe combien de puits biz point
fr tu as la carte de la france et tu
cliques sur une maison et ça explique
comment faire la bise et combien de bizi
j'étais invité chez une amie et la
famille à vraiment prendre pris leur
temps on a commencé alors avec
l'apéritif
après on a eu lors l'entrée après on a
eu le plat principal
allez après le fromage est venue après
on a mangé le dessert et tout ça a duré
mais des heures en allemagne est
ressassé jamais comme ça on allait
efficace on est vite très vite
pas avec en dessert peut-être est ce
fini quand il ya des gens qui me
demandent ça va si si non moi je dis
normal en fait si c'est un jour une
journée normale
je suis normal en fait ne s'est pas
quelque chose qu'ils savent pas où ça va
pas donc c'est normal
ici apparaît aux essais en france et
quand je dis ça ça va c'est toujours ça
va même si ça va pas c'est ça va donc
l'île de ré grave de sa va donc on sait
que ça va pas mais ça va comme ça donc
c'est tout vous je trouve un petit peu
ça oui